hey everyone hello this computer that
says hello so I'm here to talk about
HTTP to the Critias the critics have
spoken the critics have said it's a
major protocol shipped with a potential
to accelerate the web that is the HTTP -
it's enough it's supposed to make our
applications faster simpler and more
robust Google folks at web fundamentals
have mentioned that as well people who
have put together 8gb - you said it's
more efficient to parse more compact on
the wire and most importantly there are
much less error-prone compared to
textual export protocols like HTTP 1x so
lots of people are talking about HTTP 2
and how it's a lot more performance than
it is with HTTP 1 but what is it
actually so I'm here my name is erina
I work for a Morgan DB I'm an engineer
there these are my two friends who will
help me out today
- right slides and I'm gonna talk to you
about HTTP 2 and I'm gonna take it
slowly and that take it one frame at a
time this joke will be funny in like two
minutes
all right so this has got it's got this
talks got a bit of a theater wipe so
we're gonna take it in Acts and I'll
walk you through a bunch of them so the
first one's a bit of a like a prelude so
previously on HTTP files things that you
have missed if you're familiar with a
bit of like how hep-2 works this is a
refresher but those who those of you who
aren't this is a good kind of getting to
know you before we dive a little bit
deeper into the specifics of the spec
and how it works and I know Jess so the
primarily focus the primary focus of the
protocol is on performance so we want to
make sure that our web transfers are a
lot faster so specifically its focuses
on end-user perceived latency Network
and server resource usage these are the
people that maintain the HTTP - so HTTP
1
was put together in 1999 I did I had
like internet quite once a week maybe in
1999 so I don't know I don't remember
Internet in 1999 but I wanted to look at
like okay so what did Internet look like
in the time that I remember and how how
many requests are coming through
whatever transfers and there's like this
interesting tool called the HTTP archive
and it's showing you kind of like the
number of requests a number of transfers
made it goes and looks into the top 500
websites over time I think they started
in 2010 so I got the the data from 2010
which is when I remembered the internet
I don't remember it in 1999 maybe I'm
just one of those Millennials I don't
know
so in 98 in 2010 speeds were great we
weren't doing too many transfers
probably one TCP connection was enough
to be able to send one or two requests
over but in the previous year in the
previous year we've obviously increased
all of our traffic so with working with
HTTP 1 what happens is that given a
particular request we one request
happens over a single TCP connection
which means that anytime we need to be
making multiple TCP connections or
multiple requests we run them
concurrently we'll need to make multiple
connections so eventually we're just
gonna have connection after connection
after connection you can only deliver
one request at a time rather than
multiple and to be able to achieve power
parallel parallel requests you'll need
to have multiple TCP connections so what
that causes is your first packet will be
kind of in queue to be able to be
processed but all the other packets will
not be able to be processed afterwards
so they're kind of blocked so you end up
in this head-of-line blocking situation
where you can process your requests and
obviously we're doing that a lot more
than we were in 1999 or 2010 but let's
look at what an HTTP 1 server looks like
it's pretty easy
node we just create server we handle the
server we've got a request response
again a single one happens over a single
TCP connection and there we are and we
get a protocol HTTP point one point one
so what it's gp2 happened is we wanted
to increase the number of requests we
were able to make over a single TCP
connection because obviously the
head-of-line blocking doesn't work very
well so what happens with HTTP T's you
have a single connection that takes in
multiple streams and multiple streams
are able to handle multiple connections
at the given time but more on that later
this is like a little bit of an overview
and we're gonna dive deep as to what
these streams actually are and what they
do and what is a notion of request and
response and they should be - because
it's a little bit different so an HTTP
tea server and node since version 8.4
you're able to work with a create secure
service so you need a key and a cert and
this one is meant to be incompatible
mode and you're able to you create a
stream and kind of respond with the same
kind of aspect and works the same way
maybe needs a little bit more code but
it works the same way and you get an
HTTP - protocol response when you get
stuff back so it's it's a little bit
more complicated and we kind of see
these new concepts of there's this
stream that we're not quite sure about
and the stream duct responds which is
not response and in particular or rispa
you start fried head or anything like
that which is the usual HTTP 1 node API
so this one was allowing HTTP 1 to
happen which means it's compatible with
both HTTP 1 and CP 2 but there's also a
combat mode that looks a lot more
something that we're used to so you're
still getting requests a response you're
still able to create a secure server
with a key and assert to sign and you
still get their response at end and that
gets us the same result and they kind of
look similar and you're still able to
get the same HTTP protocol so htv-2
brings a couple of little winds a little
winds
that once you concentrate as we walk
through the stock one of them is stream
prioritization the other one is being
able to do something that's called
server push and another one is
compressing into TP headers so ATP 2 is
a binary protocol so you don't have the
textual responses that you would have
with HTTP 1 and so compression of HTTP 2
headers comes in and it gets utilized
and very efficiently and helps us with
the binary protocol all right so let's
talk about the connection and actually
how that happens with HTTP - so you
start off with a single connection so
this is kind of what makes up an HTTP 2
client was a client-server kind of
relationship you start off with a
connection a connection can have
multiple streams and these multiple
streams will have several frames and
frames are the unit of measure of HTTP 2
so instead of having a request response
all the data gets passed in through
frames and we'll talk about frames a
little bit further on and kind of talk
of a little bit more detail as to what's
going on there so instead a request
response all the data gets passed
through mr frames and frames are part of
your streams and those streams are part
of a TCP connection so that's already a
lot more kind of from the overview it
looks a lot more efficient than it would
with HTTP 1 so clients won't always know
ahead of time whether they can accept
whether the server can accept an HTTP 2
request so how will this kind of
connection work with the two clients so
what you start off with for the client
is you say hey I might want to I would
like to upgrade to a TP 2 if I can let's
do this and you'll pass in the
connection header as part of that and
you say that I would like to upgrade
you'll do this some alp and negotiations
on whether or not you can connect over H
if you want or HCP - I keep calling it
ALPA Alpine connection but I know it's a
LPN I just want to go to mountains maybe
I miss mountains then the server will
say that hey I can actually upgrade I
can take an HCP - we can make this an
HTTP 2 connection
I'm gonna upgrade I'm gonna send you a
101 and you can keep sending me stuff in
HTTP to rather than HTTP 1 the to the to
acknowledge there's a lot of like it's a
very kind of acknowledgment based
situation where the to acknowledge
server in the client and whether or not
something can be done or something
cannot be done it's very healthy and
then the client can then send over the
settings frame and say what it exactly
once in terms of I kind of anything that
it would require eventually from the
server it's going to let oh no in this
sitting stream so now I've talked about
frames a few times and we'll get to them
I promise in a little bit but that's
kind of how the negotiations happens and
I said I will talk about them when they
knew I would talk about him
so frames we're gonna talk about frames
so the single unit of measure and frames
lots of frames because that's how a CB 2
protocol works is that you just keep
sending over frames so that's how you
communicate between two endpoints you
send one over you send one back you some
went over a some one back so data and
headers are kind of the two you the two
that kind of come up can over and over
again eventually you might have
something like settings or window
updates that lets the client know but
one thing or another but everything gets
passed over from one to the other but if
the header block is they afford the one
and that's the one that gets compressed
that I mentioned earlier and this one
gets bundled up with a few different
ones so like the headers or the push
promise but we'll talk in a little bit
or the continuation frames so when I've
talked about the little ones compressing
HTTP headers was one of them so what
happens with the compression is that
like you would send over a couple of
[Music]
sorry so what happens with the
compression is that it kind of optimizes
instead of getting sent in plain text
and what people have discovered is that
if you keep sending them in plain text
you kind of use 500 to 800 bytes every
time but if you have cookies and a lot
of the times we'll we'll have cookies
to be sent over the wire as well it ends
up being in kilobytes so that's quite a
bit of that's kind of kind of cut a bit
of traffic to be dealing with so when
you set off headers you send them in a
like a list I'll be content type it'll
be some cookies and things like that you
send them in the list and then get put
together by the protocol in a little
block and then that block uses Huffman
encoding and I won't talk about Huffman
encoding here but that Huffman encoding
gets put together compressed in an octet
block and it's Huffman encoded so it's a
lots more smaller and it's binary
instead of being textual which is a lot
better and then like I've mentioned
previously it gets put together with the
headers the push promise or the
continuation frames there are just the
type of frames that could be sent over
by the client or the server but you
won't necessarily have to deal with them
directly when you build out your
application so we talked about streams
we talked about the fact that a TCP
connection can have multiple streams it
we talked about the fact that streams
can handle frames as we've just
mentioned in the previous scene so let's
talk about streams I I don't usually
like reading specs because I think it's
a lot of wording and like I don't like
what they put together but this is a
really good explanation from the spec so
streams are independent bi-directional
sequence of frames so frames being part
of the stream exchanged between the
client and the server was in a given
HTTP 2 connection so that's a really
good definition from a spec I like it so
a stream can have a couple of states
that it just keeps rotating over so it
can be an idle stream a reserved open
stream meaning a stream that is being
prepared to receive or send over data
and a stream that's half closed that has
finished sending over data or a closed
stream that is no longer in use so you
kind of keep moving over to those and
frames keep coming through and coming
through and eventually it gets closed
off again multiple streams exist for a
single connection instead of with HTTP
one just being the one
we've seen that before multiple streams
one connection and once you get them
through your endpoint you'll get several
frames from several streams and they can
be combined from different streams when
you receive them instead of being
instead of just being taken from the
single stream so stream prioritization I
wanted to briefly mention this a lot of
the time is when you're actually working
with a cheapy - you won't have to deal
with this unless you want to build out
your own kind of server in the client
but it's kind of interesting to know
which is why I kind of dived in deep
into this topic so because you have
multiple streams and you'll want to be
able to not have them come in at the
same time and resolve at the same time
you'll want to be prioritizing them and
that's one of the really cool things
about HTTP - is that you can prioritize
which resources you want to use where
and which ones you want to prioritize
over other ones so certain pieces of
data can be sent over faster than other
pieces of data and to be able to deal
with that what you do is you assign
string dependencies to different
portions of your of your connection and
then different weights and weights are
the ones that resolve the streams faster
so if something has a higher weight so
we have four streams here and stream 2
in steam 3 are dependent on stream 1
stream 4 is dependent on steams stream 3
so see stream 4 will not resolve before
stream 3 but since steam 3 and stream 2
on the same level or like they they're
both dependent on stream 1 they're gonna
like compete for resources but because
we've assigned weights to them we know
that stream 3 is more important with a
better weight or like a higher weight so
a resolved faster and then they don't
compete for the resources and in streams
2 will resolve after that so that's how
HCP two handles kind of resources a lot
better and a lot smarter than 81 so we
kind of talked about stream
prioritization and talked about how
we're
resources and another way of managing
resources that http/2 has is flow
control and this one's a kind of
interesting and then you're able to kind
of solve this between the client and the
server so because we have multiplex
streams over a single TCP connection
sometimes because we multiplex them that
can cause congestion on a given TCP
connection so too many of them and a
single TCP connection we need to be able
to communicate to the client as to how
many or what are the important resources
so multiplexing them helps so this
because the streams have several states
that they go through idle reserved open
have closed and closed there's only
certain ones that count towards this
flow control flow control markings and
there are the reserved open and half
closed so closed and idle don't count
but what happens is that when you send
data specifically the data frames they
count towards the number that the server
will have so server has a number that it
specifically sends over to the client
and says I can only handle this much I
can only spend or give you this many
resources at the same time so I'm gonna
let you know how are you doing it's a
credit-based system so data and headers
are the only ones that affect this and
only the streams that are reserved open
or half closed to count towards this and
every time it's like you've used parts
of that particular flow control number
sir we'll send you a window update
letting you know that hey you're kind of
you're using stuff up so it will
communicate to the client how well
you're doing in terms of you like your
credit based system and it works like a
credit-based system so you take away you
put back especially you put back when
the stream is closed so flow control
helps you prioritize streams so they
don't block and so you're able to not
over utilize and not congest your TCP
connection all right so we talked about
kind of the general concepts of HTTP -
and this will all of this applies to no
js' but I wanted to like walk you
through how
this works in nodejs and kind of what
the flow of data is between when you
receive a request from the clients and
when you send back their response so
what does know do so you start off with
having an incoming call an incoming
secure connection that comes in to your
server to your node up to your node
server what happens is that libuv will
handle parts of that i/o you will then
open up a stream in a session it's taken
the data and libous a cell will decrypt
that connection what will happen after
the connection is decrypted is TLS
termination and after that you're able
to get through and restart receiving
frames from the client including the
settings frame which I mentioned a
little bit earlier so once you start
coming once request started coming in in
forms of frames a package called a dingy
http/2 it's a c++ bucket it will start
parsing the request into frames
specifically and then those frames will
be able to send events and raw data
once those are parsed into that they are
now able to be put together in your
node.js application that you can work
with because you can't work with that
beforehand so once those events and raw
data and they're part of your node.js
application and then you as a developer
are able to handle particular things you
want to do and send back the response
back to the client so all of these
happen before you're able to actually
manipulate the response which is kind of
interesting to know because he kind of
just can work with the request response
or you can also work with the request
response and know a little bit more
about how no it handles these particular
things one of the things we talked about
that was parts of the little wins is
server push and server push is an
interesting one and then something that
was put together with HTTP 2 and I'll do
a little bit of example when we get to
this as a server push allows you to
preempt
we send data to the client before it
needs it so this puts it into the
clients cache and then once the client
needs it it doesn't have to make a
request to the server it already has the
data which is really cool so I'm gonna
use a package cause called TLS keygen I
really wanted to give a shout out to
this one because developing in localhost
and creating secure service is a little
bit hard so this package allows you to
be able to do that on localhost so you
still have the key in the cert and
you're able to create a secure server on
that I think sub for building it this
human lives in Singapore and I met them
there that was cool
so we're gonna do is streamed up push
and I will actually pull up my terminal
because it might be a little bit easier
than just on the slide so this is the
parts of the TLS key gen package that
handles your keys in the certs but what
we'll do is we'll just create a secure
server using the key in the cert and
will allow for HTTP 1 which is the
compatible mode so we can take both HTTP
1 and GPT request and what we'll do is
we'll push certain parts of data and I
thought like the the more interesting
one to do is bundle dot CSS because I
feel like with what this is useful for
is especially CSS when you're working
with a particular part of the
application and you're loading
pre-loading parts of it of the CSS that
you'll need later on is super fast and
super efficient so we're gonna do a push
stream and it takes some headers and we
know that we want to send the path
that's bundle dot CSS and when we send
back the response from the server we'll
make sure that this server actually is
sorry the client actually wants the CSS
so make sure that the stylesheet is
there and what push stream will do is
they'll respond with 200 and it'll send
back some background color
that's hot pink to match the rest of the
presentation I already had the server
running so the next thing to do is just
to actually see it I usually use a
nightly but I'm gonna use Chrome for
this because nightly has this weird
thing where I can't even see the
protocol inside of the network tab so it
just has one line I don't think we need
to see it any more so that's 8,000 and
so the background color got pushed but
the more interesting thing is to see the
network tab so I'm just gonna show you
that and refresh so we're getting to
just the localhost and we're getting the
protocol HTTP too and there's no
particular initiator but once we get to
bundle dot CSS we can see that it was
pushed preemptively and we can see that
it sent over the response that
background color is pink and the
interesting part is that regardless of
whether or not the client has to ask
you're still going to transfer the same
amount of data it's just gonna be faster
in terms of you won't have to have the
client ask you for stuff instead you
just have it there for them especially
if you know it's already there it's
something they will need so this is for
you as a developer kind of to decide
so that's server pushed and it's I think
it's a pretty cool feature all right so
the tail they are ie
what have we learned in this
presentation or hope that you've learned
in this presentation so I wanted to
mention we were talking about node HT p2
is still under the experimental flag
this is a and this is the first time I'm
telling you this but it's under
experimental tag there is like literally
yesterday James put out a discussion
issue
the node repo saying though they're
trying to get it out of the experimental
[ __ ] as soon as possible so if you're
thinking I'm using it in production
probably report some of the bugs do you
have or if you are using it in
production report the bugs you have so
we can get it as experimental tagged as
soon as possible but kind of the
takeaways is the fact that you can use
push and push allows you to preventively
preemptively and proactively send a
bunch of stuff to the client before it
needs it and loaded into clients cache
the fact that we have flow control and
the fact that we have stream
prioritization we're able to use the TCP
connection better and have better
performance gains which means you don't
have to use a single TCP connection per
request but instead you use multiple
streams in a given a request unable to
send frames over those and the fact that
the combat mode exists in nodejs who are
able to quite easily switch to http - in
fact it looks very similar - the fact
that you need the keys and certs which
you'll need anyway in an HTTP server so
it's quite easy to switch over and
that's it for me today NOFA and today
would say in the movie
yeah thanks thanks so much and thanks to
organizers and I think Lindsay is doing
life captioning thank you for that and
thank you for listening to my mumbles
come say hi I'm on Twitter and you can
email me thanks
you